for joining me now is the former Russian
Prime Minister Mikhail Casiano thank you
very much for being with us today and I
think my first question is do Russians
really believe that NATO posed this
threat to Russia as Vladimir Putin said
uh this morning or the threat to
russian-occupied territories the
Russians really believe that
I think I should admit that the
propaganda which lasted for for any
decade just created the feeling of I
would say of half of Russia's population
that NATO create the endanger on the
threat to Russia not all the population
as Mr Putin would like to to see it and
believe but a lot a lot of people
continue to believe that this the
propaganda the descriptions of all this
thread is the reality but that's why the
society in fact the split at 50 50 by 50
in Russia and right now just by the way
people started to considering and
reconsidering the attitude to what is
going on
so if 50 don't believe it and will
increasingly question the war is
President Putin in trouble do you think
uh I think yes he is already starting in
a troubled period of time and in fact
he stolen the victory they just
Remembrance Day from Russians it was
family of family memory and he used to
own this and and created the instrument
of propaganda out of this Victory Day
and in fact his cynical I would say
akharma trying to to make it equal the
war in Ukraine with the war against
Nazi Germany in the in the second world
war that is the the The crucial cynical
attitude I think I think that's already
that's already clear that he is very
angry on everything what's going around
he and in today's speech he didn't
demonstrate any enthusiasm and the main
goal he said it's not the change of the
regime it is not as he said before so
imagine dinner certification but simply
the protect protection a lot of people
living Camden bus Which is also
artificial reasoning and he tries to
change history he tries to
destroy the history in a way in a way to
somehow find justification of his brutal
war against Ukraine
yeah Michael that's really interesting
do you think then that he knows he's
miscalculated to his senior Military
Officers believe that he's miscalculated
I think that's already that's already
the case and that's uh I think I already
have feeling just watching Mr Putin on
his speech and and Timber and just in
fact the style of explaining what he
wanted to explain that's already he
already just losing this Trends I think
and uh he was misled and he didn't
expect such a uh was I would say bravery
and resistance of ukrainians ukrainians
appeared to be just too strong very much
strong to defending their land and in
fact he is briskly he's shot award
failed to take place and now we're
coming to the period of I would say
um the war of uh economic and Military
potentials and uh just the ability of
ukrainians to defend their land and the
military supplies by the Western
countries uh to Ukraine just allows to
to expect that the upcoming future
Ukraine could achieve could get could
get a decisive Advantage a military
advantage on a battlefield and in this
case just beginning of putting uh ERA
with the the start
beginning of the ends of Putin's era
would start immediately
so um let's just be clear what you're
saying there almost whatever happens now
whatever Victory he tries to claim you
think this could well be the beginning
of the end of of Vladimir Putin
yes and today Mr Putin didn't announce
any Victory he called for future Victory
but today he said we're fighting we're
fighting against Nazi whatever just he
imagined just in his explanation of the
threat but it's absolutely just
certainly in his mind but it's nothing
to do with reality and but there was no
any statement about just the positive
achievements and just not saying Victory
he called for future Victory it means he
already losing he raised or were you
losing the strengths and I think just
all those generals and officers who was
watching are listening he's this morning
just already understood they got this
feeling already just a weakness
so what do you think then that President
Putin will decide that a victory looks
like if you see what I'm saying I mean
he had his you know he had his big
Ambitions at the beginning of this what
do you think he will be looking at now
as a victory that he could
walk away with and sell to the Russian
people right he he just minimized his
appetite I would say just
by by achieving the operating at land
Corridor land Corridor between donbass
and Crimea Crimea for him is crucial
Point that's and he's in his I would say
I wouldn't say cut but that is the major
achievement he believes for for his 25
22 years of rule and that's why that is
very
sensitive uh extremely sensitive Point
Crimea anyone in his speech okay
mentioned today that there was a threat
on our historical lands including kremi
he emphasized he already said that is
like a historical land of Russia that's
another reason why the Russia annexed
Crimea why Putin yeah it's important
that was his achievement he believes
that he will be able to sell to Russians
that the land corridority
okay thank you very much indeed Mikhail
cassianov thank you appreciate your time